all right welcome everybody to this
year's George Herbert Walker lecture in
international george herbert walker jr.
lecture in International Studies I'm
Steven Wilkinson the director of the
Macmillan Center here at Yale we welcome
you to this newly renovated place with
surround sound and all manner of of new
tech facilities so what are what is the
George Herbert Walker jr. lecture in
International Studies the Honorable
George Herbert Walker the third Yale
College class of 1953 and honoree u.s.
sorry and former US ambassador to the
Republic of Hungary established this
lecture series in 1986 in memory of his
father who was a distinguished graduate
of the Yale College class of 1927
so the Walker lecture is a signature
lecture presented each year by the
Macmillan Center and is featured in the
past eminent polity policy practitioners
and scholars such as Madeleine Albright
Albright Richard Holbrooke and UN
Secretary Ban Ki moon I'm very very
pleased that there are several Walker
family members with us here today for
the lecture and we welcome them here so
today's speaker ambassador Cole Chacon
is the former permanent permanent
secretary of the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs of Singapore which is the the
top civil servant in charge of foreign
affairs in that system and was
ambassador-at-large until May 2018
he's currently chairman of the Middle
East Institute at the National
University of Singapore as one of
Singapore's leading diplomats and
strategists he served the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs as deputy secretary for
Southeast Asia the permanent
representative to the UN in New York and
the ambassador to the Russian Federation
he's the author of numerous books
including dealing with an ambiguous
world and Singapore is not an island
so today he's going to speak to us about
how the US should think about Southeast
Asia prepare yourself for a very
insightful smart gracious and having met
him witty
talk for these are his hallmarks please
join me in welcoming ambassador Billa
Hari Kousaka
[Applause]
that was far too kind an introduction I
thank you for the honor of delivering
this lecture I just hope that those who
invited me will not conclude it was an
act of reckless folly
how should Americans thing about
Southeast Asia let me start with a story
some years ago when I was still in
Singapore foreign ministry I asked a
Vietnamese friend my counterpart in the
Vietnamese Foreign Service in fact what
an impending change of leadership in
Hanoi would mean for Vietnam's relations
with China
his reply every Vietnamese leader he
said must be able to get along with
China every Vietnamese leader must be
able to stand up to China and if you
think you cannot do both at the same
time you do not deserve to be leader I
start with this anecdote because at
least in my view Americans have always
had some difficulty in thinking
appropriately about Southeast Asia the
most persistent American error has been
to force complicated Southeast Asian
realities into simplistic and a
historical frameworks based on
considerations they do not sufficiently
integrate local realities the United
States has generally viewed Southeast
Asia primarily through the lens of
strategic competition with other major
powers Southeast Asia has been far more
an arena than a region to be dealt with
on his own terms and this has often
proven self subverting for most of the
twentieth century US policy in Southeast
Asia was shaped by Cold War
considerations and this was entirely
understandable perhaps unavoidable were
nevertheless also inadequate Sarris Asia
is one of the most diverse regions in
the world coram parities were entangled
with processes of the
which were in turn inextricably linked
to local dynamics based on competing
nationalisms which were themselves
subject to powerful ethnic and religious
forces ignoring such complexities meet
the second Vietnam War the archetypical
example of the failure of American
policy in Southeast Asia actually there
is another view about the Vietnam War
which perhaps we can talk to about in in
question time well cold war imperatives
have now been replaced by those of us
China relations and what both frameworks
the Cold War framework and the us-china
competition framework have in common is
that they encourage a binary mode of
thought a binary mental framework is one
that assumes that anything must be one
thing or another and if not one thing
necessarily only the other if South Asia
is not free it will become red if
America does not maintain his primacy
the region will fall into China's
clutches democracy is either steadily
advancing or it has been forced into
retreat and if ASEAN the Association of
Southeast Asian Nations cannot do
everything it is not worth considering
well as my Vietnamese friends reply
illustrates policymakers in Southeast
Asia generally do not think in the same
way we see no reason why we should be
only one thing or another the inability
to appreciate how policymakers in
Southeast Asia thing is a liability for
American policy in the region and I
spent almost 40 years trying to persuade
American policymakers journalists and
academics to think about Southeast Asia
in more nuanced ways that is if they
think about Southeast Asia at all I have
not noticed that my efforts have had
anything more than minor and ephemeral
effects
I nevertheless persists and I persist
not because I am irredeemably stubborn
or because I get some obscure pleasure
in banging my head against the wall I
persist because the US has always had
and will always have a crucial influence
on the International Relations of
Southeast Asia and this is so
irrespective of whether American policy
succeeds or fails now America's
relations with China have entered a new
long-term phase from 1972 when the US
and China re-established contact after
the communist revolution until about
2008 or 2009 or there abouts despite
periods of tension and competition the
overall emphasis of us-china relations
was on engagement that emphasis has now
flipped engaged were not entirely cease
but the long-term emphasis is clearly
now on strategic competition Southeast
Asia will increasingly become the focal
point of us-china competition in a way
that the region never was during the
Cold War when it was only a secondary or
indeed a peripheral theater of us-soviet
competition us-china competition will be
more complicated than us-soviet
competition it is therefore more
important than ever before that the us
better understand Southeast Asia and I
thank your University for giving me
another opportunity to try to get my
American friends to think appropriately
about Southeast Asia this is an honor
which I am not sure I deserve but
Singaporeans are not known for passing
up opportunities whether or not we
deserve them
since I have learned not to be very
hopeful about the effect of what I have
to say please take my remarks only as an
invitation to a dialogue and I look
forward to your questions
now us-china competition is highly
unlikely to lead to war as the US Soviet
competition by proxy in mainland
sowas Asia the US and China are not
destined for war to quote the title of a
rather silly book by an otherwise great
scholar but neither is us-china
competition likely to have as clear a
denouement as did the Cold War neither
the u.s. nor China are likely to achieve
their goals in entirety a messy an
indeterminate outcome is implicit in
what my Vietnamese friend told me an
American regional order is not going to
be replaced by a Chinese regional order
in Southeast Asia if only because it was
not an American regional order in the
first place international relations
theory and I must confess I have no
great fan of international relations
theory international relations theory
generally regards hedging balancing and
bandwagoning as alternative strategies
for small countries dealing with major
power competition but what my Vietnamese
friend told me is emblematic of the
instinct to hitch balance and bandwagon
simultaneously that is deeply imprinted
in the diplomatic DNA of all Southeast
Asian countries this is not well
understood by most Americans who
sometimes seem to assume that we
necessarily should define our interests
only in terms of American interests and
values and we don't follow America's
lead it is only because of our ignorance
or recalcitrant recalcitrance their
instinct to grip the hidden along the
path of righteousness remains strong but
forgetting that we but forgetting that
we do have our own interests and values
is not a plus for American policy let me
give you an example the 30s election as
president of the Philippines in 2016 and
his attempt to improve relations with
China over the disputes in the South
China Sea is an example of binary
thinking after duty a visitor China
the New York Times concluded and I quote
Philippines deal with China pokes a hole
in US strategy and cold
and too many American policymakers and
scholars diplays displayed much the same
attitude but was the Tate a wrong to
recalibrate relations with China when it
was clear that the US was not going to
defend the Philippines if he got into a
conflict with China over the South China
Sea
the Philippines then and now has no Navy
or Air Force worth talking about
Duterte has a streak of anti-americanism
that streak is never absent from
Filipino nationalism but he has not
renounced the u.s. alliance and
significantly improved relations with
Japan America's principal ally in East
Asia know is here Brandon Philippines
claims in the South China Sea
Filipino attitudes towards the u.s. have
always been ambivalent an attitude
nicely captured by a joke that was
current when the u.s. withdrew from
Subic air base and Clark Subic so big
bay and Clark airfield in the early
1990s Yankee go home and take me with
you
now ambivalence is a characteristic of
all Southeast Asian attitudes towards
the US and other major powers including
China in fact I would argue probably
more so in the case of China now when I
point this out some American friends
chide me for posting what they consider
moral equivalence between China and the
US but the relevant concept in
international relations is not morality
but interests we in Southeast Asia were
naturally sometimes tilt one way and
sometimes the other as our interesting
tip and sometimes go our own way even if
this pleases both the US and China
simultaneously this flexible approach
implies no moral judgment any particular
decision is necessarily always
situational and conditional and
contingent upon specific circumstances
in which the domestic politics of key
Southeast Asian states is often a
critical influence Americans often cite
domestic policy
when trying to explain shifts in u.s.
politics policies which is true enough
but we do have our own domestic politics
which is no less insistent in a 1950s
and 1960s the Soviet Union invested
heavily in political and military terms
in Sukarno's Indonesia but that did not
prevent Sukarno and PKI the Indonesian
Communist Party turning towards Beijing
for reasons there were almost entirely
domestic close relations flows
Indonesian relations with China
collapsed after fail 1965 who brought to
heart or to power and this change in
Indonesia's domestic politics was the
single most important and decisive
influence on Southeast Asia's subsequent
trajectory and led among other things to
the formation of ASEAN the Association
of Southeast Asian Nations which
stabilized the region once known as the
Balkans of Asia more on asean later for
now let me just draw your attention to
the fact that the friendlier attitude of
Suharto and his successors to us the
west has not prevented jakarta from
pursuing his long-standing bebas done
active in which translates as free and
active foreign policy which is sometimes
at odds with the US and his friends and
allies in additions have a long history
of taking money from all major powers
and doing what they want anyway in 2015
Japan lost a contract to China for a
high-speed rail between Jakarta and
Bandung I told my Japanese friends not
to be downhearted
because they would soon thank the
Indonesians for giving that contract to
the Chinese and that project has proved
since proven a headache to the Chinese
although others with the Chinese have
moved forward more smoothly the new
nations of also gave other arguably more
important contracts to the Japanese in
fact how do you build one dune is on a
mountain
Jakarta is in a delta how do you build a
high-speed rail up a mountain I don't
know so I don't think it was a very good
project in the first place
as an aside let me point out that the
stock and quality of American and
Japanese investment in South Asia is
still far greater than Chinese
investment and although Chinese trade
and investment is bound to increase
further the changes are relative not
absolute and the US and its allies in
Japan and Europe will remain key
economic partners for us in Southeast
Asia even as China grows in importance
it's not a binary choice again ASEAN is
promiscuous with free trade agreements
ASEAN has free trade agreements with
Japan Australia New Zealand the ROK and
India as well as China several US and
states are members of the TPP 11 I call
it the TPP 11 because the real title is
quite a mouthful and I'm not going to
repeat it Singapore and Vietnam have
joined the Eurasian Economic Union
Singapore has an FTA with the US and the
EU and several other ASEAN members are
negotiating FTAs with the U so we are
promised with the FTA we do not want to
have just one economic partner and
however important China will be it is
not going to ever be our sole or even
the dominant economic partner in any
case trade and investment are not favors
one country does for another the
benefits are mutual and so therefore two
are the costs of withholding trade and
investment if it is done for political
and strategic reasons an obvious point
but one that is too often overlooked and
the larger point is that a setback for
the u.s. for US policy or the policies
of his allies like Japan does not
necessarily translate to a clear victory
for America's competitors what I have
described in the cases of the
Philippines and Indonesia is true in
different ways and degrees of every
other South Asian country examples
available on request
during question time the only partial
exception I can think of
Cambodia under his present leadership
but since consent must eventually go the
way of all mortal flesh the policies of
his highly personalized system are
likely under to undergo modification
which will no doubt temper the grief of
his passing for the nari Cambodians
Southeast Asia is located at the
strategic crossroads between the Pacific
and Indian Oceans a geopolitical fact
underscored by the new term Indo Pacific
as such he has always been a region
where the interests of several major
powers have always intersected and
sometimes collided major powers have
always asserted a significant influence
on Southeast Asia where they have seldom
been the exclusive or decisive influence
Seleucid is to often repeat the dictum
you know it the strong do what they can
and the weak suffer what they must is
only crude crude realism implicit in
what my men met nummies friends said in
reply to my question is the idea that
crude realism is sometimes not very
realistic post-world war two hours each
Asia World War to Southeast Asia can be
understood as the unending search by the
small countries of the region for
autonomy in the midst of great power
major power competition competition
between the major powers often poses
complex challenges for us but complexity
also creates agency Southeast Asia and
the larger Indo Pacific in which it is
embedded is a naturally multi polar
region China as a big contiguous country
will always enjoy significant influence
in Southeast Asia but the most
symmetrical strategic equation is
emerging between the US and China does
not mean that the US will suddenly
disappear the adjustments are again
relative not absolute now one of the
tropes about u.s. foreign policy
that emerge under after the 2016
election is that America and the Donald
Trump is now in retreat but the trauma
administration has unambiguously signal
his intention to compete robustly with
China and has begun to do so we trade
and restrictions on technology transfers
as its preferred instruments now
whatever you may think about these
policies and I am NOT personally filled
with joy about them I do not see how
they can be accurately described as a
retreat in any case I see no sign of
America retreating from Sarris Asia
Japan de is now playing a more
independent role with India u.s.
alliance system is also emerging as a
significant strategic player and will
likely continue to do so beyond the RBA
government so too is Australia playing a
bigger role India is another big
contiguous country that will always have
a role in Southeast Asia
although New Delhi may not always meet
our perhaps inflated expectations and
Indonesia and Vietnam are part of the
region and not inconsequential countries
even some European countries are now
trying to play a strategic role in
Southeast Asia European efforts will
never amount to very much in the overall
strategic balance but it is always
useful to have a few more flags
fluttering in the winds of the South
China Sea the diversity of Southeast
Asia and the instinct to simultaneously
h balance and bandwagon encourages the
natural multipolarity of the region
there is no major power that will find
itself entirely unwelcome or without
some sort of a role in Southeast Asia it
is a historical fact that no major power
has ever been able to capture Southeast
Asia in entirety the Japanese occupation
during the second world war was
historically short an exceptional s was
the period of unquestioned American
dominance from about 1991 to circa 2009
Southeast Asia is now returning to
more historically normal state now
multipolarity does not mean that the
different poles will necessarily be or
equal weight in every policy domain
sometimes America will be heavier than
China let's say in the military domain
and China may be heavier than America in
some other domain and Japan in some
other and so on and so forth but even if
asymmetrical multipolarity creates the
possibility of manoeuvre for the small
countries of South Asia now I do not
claim the realist maneuver very well
where opportunities for manoeuvre are
never entirely absent and are likely to
increase as the region's natural
multipolarity asserts itself whether we
have the wit to recognize the
opportunities and the courage to act
upon them is of course another matter
but to succumb to a sense of fatalism is
almost always fatal to small states and
this was the tragic fate of C annex
Cambodia and royal is lost in the 1960s
when discombobulated by the vicissitudes
of American domestic attitudes towards
the Vietnam War they sought security in
non-alignment and neutrality in short by
lying low and hoping not to be noticed
we know what happened to them what the
Cambodian and Laotian experience
illustrate is that the perception of the
u.s. is a crucial variable in
determining salvation responses to
particular situations it's obvious that
the Trump administration has taken the
unpredictability always inherent in
American political cycle to new levels
but is also important not to forget that
unilateralism a preference for
bilateralism over multilateralism
coercion as an instrument of policy
disquiet over free trade among other
things were not inventions by mr. Donald
Trump they have always existed the
shining city upon a hill has always also
cast a dark shadow still too much of our
information in Southeast Asia about the
u.s. comes from the Western media whose
biases are not always easily this
to those in my region you should not
assume that everybody in Southeast Asia
understands the US political system or
the US media as many people in a America
seem to assume there is of course much
to criticize but roughly sometimes seems
to me that the American media reports on
American foreign policy as if everything
mr. Trump does is wrong great cow power
competition is as much psychological as
material and pretending that nothing
that the Trump administration does is
right is a serious liability again
examples on request during question time
viewing South Asia two frameworks that
do not sufficiently take local realities
into account invest American policy with
more inconsistency than necessary
attention is pyretic and ad hoc too much
focus on events they catch the headlines
and not enough on long-term trends and
processes after the end of the Cold War
insofar as the Clinton administration
thought about South Asia it assessed
regional developments largely as
opportunities for the advance or retreat
of democracy defined in western terms
another over simplistic binary framework
when the Asian financial crisis made it
impossible for so Hato to continue in
office the Clinton administration
adopted a policy of democracy promotion
by decapitation as if the intricate
internal structures and relationships of
a 30-year old system could be replaced
at a single stroke by removing one
individual a subsequent two decades of
five Indonesian presence and too many
ill-considered policies whose effects
are still unfolding and when the
consequences of removing so hotter were
not as straightforward as the Clinton
administration expected it unilaterally
declared victory for democracy and it
turned its attention elsewhere ignoring
the consequences that did not fit its
own ideas what are the most serious
effects of the Clinton
administration's ill-considered policy
of democracy for promotion in Indonesia
was the unleashing of political Islam in
Oceania has still not reached a stable
post Suharto equilibrium and the impact
of the growing influence of political
Islam coupled with the phenomenon that
could be characterized as the
Arabization of salvation Islam may well
posed a greater long-term challenge to
American interests in Southeast Asia
than China 9/11 led the Bush 43
administration into middle-eastern
adventures that distracted the u.s. and
gave China well-nigh a free hand for
almost a decade terrorism and
counterterrorism became the chief US
Precog preoccupations about in Southeast
Asia the Bush 43 administration was not
ILDA toast was a.cian in fact it was
quite friendly while I remember telling
mr. Armitage who was then deputy
secretary it would be nice if I knew
that Americans thought about Southeast
Asia for other reasons then you suspect
that some of us are trying to kill you
anyway it was extremely difficult to get
serious attention from the
administration despite his friendliness
for audience effort to build a post Cold
War regional architecture until the very
end of the administration whereupon time
ran out and a new administration had to
be educated almost all over again the
Obama administration's pivot or
rebalance to Asia was intended to
redress the omissions of its predecessor
and this was welcomed as far as it went
but those were nevertheless
inappropriate indeed somewhat silly
metaphors that raised expectations that
the administration could not fulfill and
perhaps had no intention of fulfilling
the Obama administration took ASEAN
diplomacy more seriously than any of his
predecessors and began to support at
least inform our science efforts to
build a post COBOL regional architecture
Wow President Obama made good speeches
his administration had
little stomach for competition and this
fundamental purpose of the root new
regional architecture that ASEAN was
trying to erect it was in fact to manage
major power competition now this was an
endeavor that was beyond what ASEAN
could realistically achieve by itself it
was during Obama's watch that the South
China Sea emerged as something of a
proxy for the adjustments under way in
us-china relations and this is and
remains a big boys game we have been
there before during the sino-soviet
proxy conflict over Cambodia in the
1980s ASEAN role who are not
inconsequential was clearly secondary
and what we required was not just nice
speeches but the backstop of power that
only the US could provide
unlike the Reagan administration in the
1980s the Obama administration was not a
reliable backstop it was a grievous
error for the Obama administration to
have brokered a deal between China and
the Philippines over the disputes over
Scarborough Shoal in the South China Sea
but then do nothing when China promptly
broke the deal the consequences are
still with us in some respects mr. Trump
has been better than mr. Obama Trump's
cancellation of the TPP the
trans-pacific partnership was certainly
a blow to American credibility why was
no less severe a blow to American
credibility when Obama shrank from
enforcing the redline he drew over the
use of chemical weapons in Syria when
Trump bomb Sevilla over the same issue
while having dinner with Xi Jinping he
did much to restore the credibility of
American power now tom has been
criticized for his lack of enthusiasm
for democracy and human rights promotion
but on this issue in Southeast Asia
Obama and Trump are perhaps more alike
than either would care to admit one of
the most important strategic moves by
Obama in Southeast Asia
was his opening to a mama which was not
den a democracy in western terms and
were very probably never evolved into a
western-style democracy if many in the
US have been disillusioned by Jung
sang-soo cheese Miyama this is much more
due to unrealistic expectations arising
from the imposition of simplistic binary
narratives of the advance or retreat on
democracy on complex Miyama realities
than American policy failures and if mr.
Trump has been indifferent to cause to
reimpose blanket sanctions on Miami
there is all to the good in strategic
terms and essentially a continuation of
Obama's policy during the second Obama
administration the Pentagon tried to
mitigate the first Obama
administration's mistake over
Scarborough Shoal by conducting phone
ops freedom of navigation operations to
challenge Chinese claims in the South
China Sea but public differences between
the Pentagon and Susan Rice's national
security council undermined the affair
and in this respect the Trump
administration has certainly done far
better by upping the frequency of phone
ops without indulging in quasi
metaphysical public debates over whether
or not Israeli or not they just do it
situation in the South China Sea is now
a strategic stalemate this is not ideal
but the best that can be expected given
mistakes by previous previous
administrations stretching back to the
bush 41 administration during which time
the South China Sea first emerges an
issue between China and ASEAN and I
recall very clearly Secretary of State
Baker having to be persuaded to even
stay a very mild statement of American
principle on that dispute in any case
what happens on land in Southeast Asia
is as important a part of the regional
architecture as what happens at sea the
Mekong whose headwaters are in China
runs through half of ASEAN and since the
end of the second Vietnam War the land
has been persistently neglected by
successive us administrations indeed the
land has been neglected
by asean itself beyond the integration
of Vietnam Cambodia Laos and Myanmar
within the asean framework which has
created a whole new set of challenges
these challenges and asean itself are
not well understood asean does some
things very well you can only partially
deal with other things and some things
are beyond his powers the essence of
dealing with asean is to know the
difference between these categories of
issues and accordingly ASEAN is
certainly not a perfect organization
there is no perfection to be found on
earth but far too much criticism of
ASEAN amounts to criticizing a cow for
being an imperfect horse and this is
utterly pointless a science fundamental
and enduring purpose is to ensure at
least a modicum of civility and order
among its members we are not a happy
Band of Brothers if we were a happy Band
of Brothers there would be no need for
us yet every project the ASEAN
undertakes is as important as a means to
this basic goal maintaining at least a
modicum of order and civility in
relations among its members as it is an
end in itself and a science basic
consensus is always to have a consensus
even if it is only a consensus of form
or consensus or not having a consensus
order in Southeast Asia and civility in
intra-regional relationships was never
to be taken for granted given the state
of the region in 1967 the year the asean
was established that its members have
since experienced tensions and minor
conflicts in their relationships but not
war and that south asia after the end of
the third Indochina war has been a peace
is a considerable achievement for which
credit must be given to ASEAN but
although the tensions and conflicts that
bedevil Southeast Asia before 1967 have
been considerably mitigated they
not been erased and probably never will
entirely disappear Southeast Asia is not
a natural region that can be defined by
something intrinsic to itself
paradoxically the only intrinsic
characteristic of Southeast Asia is that
there is nothing intrinsic to Southeast
Asia the diversities that define
Southeast Asia their only common
characteristic is its diverse the
diversity are not relatively superficial
differences not just relatively
superficial differences of political
systems and levels of Economic
Development more fundamentally South
Asia is characterized by primordial and
visceral diversity of race of language
and of religion and these define the
core national identities we shape the
dynamics of the domestic politics of
Southeast Asian states and their
relationships with each other
the forever not very far beneath surface
civilities from time to time they emerge
in new forms that continually need to be
managed
whatever is imperfections if ASEAN did
not exist we would therefore have to
invent something very much like it to
keep the peace in fact it's a fact very
little known that it was an American
scholar Russell Fifield who I think in
1963 or 64 wrote a book for American
policy in Southeast Asia in which he
proposed after the failure Seto that
regional organization with a membership
it eventually took with the name
Association of Southeast Asian Nations
before this role of this American
scholar is not well known although
sometime in the early 1980s I can't
remember exactly when the ASEAN foreign
ministers mystify he was still alive 10
invited him to other meetings and
enology and honored him for his
contribution in a case if he did not
exist we will have to invent something
very much like it implicit in what I've
said that its fundamental purpose is to
mend
and maintain to manage relations between
his members is the fact that ASEAN is an
interstate organization that can do no
more than his members allow it to do
with no supranational ambitions to
attempt to put into effect such
ambitions will immediately pick one
nationalism against another and risk
returning Southeast Asia to his pre-1967
state of nature it follows that ASEAN
can only operate by consensus and it's
calorie non-interference in each other's
domestic affairs this reassures small
members that big members were not
imposed their will on them and it
reassures big members that the others
were not gang up against them any other
method of decision making poses an
unacceptable risk of even small
disagreements escalating into major
conflicts decision making by consensus
is clearly less than ideal and sometimes
leaves ASEAN unable to act
it's obviously harder to reach consensus
between 10 SEC's of national interest
and 5 or 6 as in the past but ASEAN
strengths and weaknesses are different
sides of the same coin and sub optimal
decision making is the price we pay for
having any sort of regional organization
at all maintaining at least a modicum of
order and civility in intra-regional
relationships mitigates and helps manage
the inescapable reality of living in the
midst of great power competition it
occasionally helps us leverage on
competition to our advantage and this is
the basis of that overused but ill
understood term asean centrality asean
is central because it is cohesive enough
to be useful to major powers on some
issues while not being strong enough to
be a serious impediment to their most
vital interests in ninety in 2004 a
chinese vice minister in the presence of
Foreign Minister Wang Yi bluntly told
ASEAN foreign ministers to China ASEAN
was not central on the South China Sea
now that Vice Minister was rude but not
wrong nor was his general attitude
unique until the Obama administration
opened up to me ama ASEAN was certainly
not central to US policy on Miyama
although American officials as Secretary
of State's were generally more polite
about that fact then that I say that
Chinese Vice Minister accepting the
harsh reality of asymmetrical power and
working within it is the key reason why
RCN has survived while earlier
experiments in Southeast Asian regional
organization did not there is why
despite all their complaints about ASEAN
major powers still attend ASEAN meetings
are science preferred regional
architecture is one that encourages all
major powers to engage the region this
is the core purpose of the ASEAN
Regional Forum and the East Asia Summit
which are often derided as talk shops
what talking is better than fighting and
the purpose of these forums is not
problem solving but maximizing manoeuvre
space and hence autonomy were promoting
an omnidirectional and dynamic
equilibrium in which all states religion
of an interest in Southeast Asia and in
particular the major powers are never
excluded in a dynamic equilibrium the
amount of space and autonomy certainly
will vary from issue to issue your wax
and wane as circumstances change but so
long as all the majors powers are
present there will always be some space
on some issues this is not an ideal
arrangement only a practical one
our ladies and gentlemen the focus of
this already too long lecture has been
on American policy to Asami's Asia but I
do not want to leave you with the
impression that only America
misunderstands the region I do not have
time to go into them in detail by China
too has made and is still making serious
mistakes in Southeast Asia and I hope
someone will ask me about them during
Question Time nor do I want you to don't
do I want to leave you with the
impression that the US has only
liabilities in Southeast Asia
a survey earlier this year of attitudes
or ASEAN elites by the Institute of
Southeast Asian Studies in Singapore the
author which is in the audience Latino
audience somewhere because she's doing a
PhD in here right now
well that survey earlier this year
showed that all ASEAN countries trusted
China the list of all the major powers
Japan was the most trusted followed by
the U the US and India and the same
survey showed that China distrusted
China the most of all the major powers
with the u.s. a close second
unfortunately followed by India the EU
with Japan the least distrusted beyond
the survey results there is ample
anecdotal evidence that understanding of
the vital and irreplaceable role of the
US military presence in Southeast Asia
has significantly improved over the
years in 1990 after American forces
withdrew from the Philippines Singapore
concluded mou that allow US forces to
use some of our military facilities our
neighbors then reacted with outrage as
if we had sold their first born into
slavery but when the men that MOU was
renewed and enhanced significantly
enhanced in 2005 there was nary a
whimper of protests and when it was
renewed again last week for another 15
years
it was barely notice which is a good
thing and it shows that the u.s.
strategic position in Southeast Asia is
not unfavorable ladies and gentlemen
thank you for listening so patiently to
me are we now very happy to take some of
your questions
oh there's a question in a bit well I
don't think we are our orc ever can be a
very effective intermediate intermediary
in intra Southeast Asia
conflicts for the simple reason we are
an outlier in Southeast Asia in many
ways for a start we are a the only
majority ethnic Chinese country our only
country with the majority ethnic Chinese
population we are not a Chinese country
we do not define ourselves that way in a
region where the overseas Chinese are
usually not a very welcomed minority and
that colors everything we do however we
can occasionally played a role in in
where there are conflicts or where there
are Oh put it very bluntly I mean I am I
trying to find many words we
occasionally play a role in stopping our
ASEAN brothers doing stupid things
this will be the major powers all right
for example
there was this thing called the South
East Asian nuclear weapon-free zone
which is a subset of something for zone
of peace freedom and neutrality which is
based on the superficially attractive
but completely impractical idea that all
the all the regions hills everything bad
he fails the region is because of the
major powers being engaged in the region
of course ignores the obvious fact is
that how do you get the major powers out
of the region and what do you do if they
refuse to leave and they are did at
least two major powers they are
contiguous to the region China India
well we played a role in actually
blocking this idea of Association
nuclear weapon-free zone until it was
the event until we negotiated the treaty
that made it effectively useless then we
signed on the dotted line with the rest
of our awesome brothers it is in a
similar way when the Philippines for
entirely domestic political purposes
kicked up a fuss about the US presence
in you know Clark Air Field and Subic
Bay and you finally got fed up and with
a little help from a volcano less the
Philippines were shocked because we
didn't really mean it I know I remember
my father telling me look you know we
did very minute well sorry you know the
Americans meant it you know if you don't
know welcome why should they stay so we
did play a role in opening our
facilities they are no substitute for
pop or Subic Bay so that there is at
least a residue of American presence in
the region and of course we took some
flak for it until common sense
reasserted yourself in our brothers and
as I told you just as I concluded you
know people saw the value so they are
cheese-making of us they may not be
prepared to host American forces as we
do but they're no longer object to it
and they hide behind us and
so that's the kind of role we can play
but very hard for us to play a law when
let's say Thailand and Cambodia they had
a border dispute we are not stupid we
only look stupid you're not jumping into
that one behind you there's a mic well
first of all I'll give you three three
examples first of all small countries
living on the periphery of big countries
are always going to feel a degree in
scientific countries and big countries
have a duty to reassure which China has
singularly not performed in fact they
seem on time sometimes to go to the
other extreme South China Sea is one
example but it even do these things in
small matters I remember when I was
still in the foreign ministry one of my
counterparts came to me fuming mad and
asked me look when you chairman ASEAN
what did you do for the Chinese is so
special and I said nothing we refused to
do anything special for the Chinese we
treated them just like any other
dialogue China
he said no wonder now they're demanding
special treatment for me I'll give it an
example he told me it's custom when you
have a summit with between ASEAN and is
dialogue partners which include you know
China India and so on the host country
allocates hotels to each delegation so
that there is a nice trip well when my
friend was host
escaped us him and say to say nobody
treat especially we want to stay in this
particular hotel and can only stay in
this particular hotel that Hotel had
already been allocated to the Sultan of
Brunei in his dedication but the Chinese
insisted banged the tables formed at the
mouth
kicked their heels against the wall bang
their head against the wall and finally
my friend gave way no hado the Chinese
delegation I have time was premier Wen's
about do you think the premier wouldn't
about knew where he was staying
you think it wise this one say
ambassador behaved that way and there
are many more examples of such behavior
that's a small example but when you
behave that way in small ways you know
make yourself loved no matter how
influential you are and Chinese
diplomats are constantly puzzled by what
they consider a lack of gratitude of
ASEAN countries towards their generosity
well ok second example let me tell you
something I told you just a moment ago
that the position of all these Chinese
in Southeast Asia is always going to be
sensitive
that is why Singapore despite having a
majority ethnic Chinese population does
not define itself as a Chinese country
the Chinese constantly refer to us as a
Chinese country we constantly tell them
we are not a Chinese country and there's
a distinction because we don't consider
such that way we don't organize our self
that way you know our major language is
English when we when say my Prime
Minister Lee sang-ho when he meets
Chinese leaders and officials it's
perfectly fluent in Mandarin we all it
is a matter of policy when we meet
Chinese counterparts officially we speak
in English right but anyway that it and
it's as much for our neighbors because
we don't want only it was to consider us
a Chinese country either now in 1955
that the PRC
did something very wise they made a
distinction between horan which is
ethnic Chinese and wotl which is
PRC citizens and basically say ethnic
Chinese going be good citizens or
whatever country you are but under
sitting paying that distinction has been
much it has been blood very deliberately
there are any number of speeches
teaching ping has made that blurred that
distinction which is incredibly stupid
thing to do and organizationally they
have done something that is so stupid I
cannot explain because these are not
unintelligent people you know there was
a overseas Chinese Affairs Department
which is a state function that's nothing
particularly unusual about a country
having you know a department to deal
with it nice poorer India has one israel
has one and so on but this is to
nineteen last year last year for reasons
that I cannot explain Xi Jinping
put the overseas Chinese Department
under the control of the United Front
work department which is a party
function now you know what the United
Front does right it fosters fifth
columns now there are and have used the
Chinese it's obvious Asia for their
purpose but why make it so open and
transparent it was an incredibly stupid
thing to do now nobody is going to shun
China because of this but it will
certainly be really question marks in
Addis in effect in most Asian countries
I know it was in Indonesia I know it is
in Malaysia
even in Yama and Thailand and certainly
in Vietnam right why let me give you
another example it's a consequence of
that last year Malaysia had a general
election you know Malaysian political
parties are recently organized there are
many parties of several kinds as a
couple of Chinese parties and so on
right last year for reasons which I
cannot understand again the Chinese
ambassador PRC ambassador to Malaysia
during the general si
election went to campaign for the
president of the Malaysian Chinese
Association of political party in
now how is that a good idea it is wrong
in so many dimensions I can't even begin
to explain how it's wrong and needless
to say that gentleman lost his seat
badly hey by the way doing a campaign he
used pictures of see chipping and other
what is that got to do immolation
politics see they do stupid things huh I
think it's because he Jinping saying CTP
claims the loyalty of all Chinese and
there were orders given and in zipping
CT brings China the consequence of not
being sufficiently enthusiastic about
carrying out orders however foolish a
quite dire so you have intelligent
people in Southeast Asia doing quite
stupid things that's the other examples
the third thing which is a latent
problem is India
I don't think any government of a Muslim
majority country whether in Southeast
Asia or anywhere else since my
retirement I've been traveling a lot in
Central Asia for example and and I am in
charge of the Middle East instead I
don't know any government now is eager
to pick a fight over the you guys for a
variety of different reasons some of
them are even harsher on their political
Islamist and the Chinese are some of
them don't really consider these people
real Muslims Idaho sofa of reasons and
sorry they want to suck up to China but
it doesn't mean that their peoples are
unaware of this I in fact it became a
small issue in the Malaysian during
election last year it wasn't a small
issue in the Indonesian election earlier
this year not big issue where's dead let
me say it's an awareness and they said
Nia where does in Central Asia now my
Chinese friends say no nothing will
happen
I tell them Mia maybe nothing will
happen perhaps nothing will happen
I have something will happen even as we
speak where something will happen next
year or the year after
in other words you have a sword of
Damocles hanging over your head
which you put there yourself nobody hung
it
there because I remind my Chinese
friends that in the Salman Rushdie
affair and in the fair of the English
cartoons no government either want to
make a big fuss but the people suddenly
caught fire and they had to make a fuss
I like to quote Nazi Tom to my Chinese
friends on this issue a single spot can
start a prairie fire now very single
spark may not come he may have a come
but it's it gives a certain
vulnerability and brittleness to Chinese
policy in Southeast Asia which is the
second largest Muslim population the
world after India its larger the middle
Issa a certain vulnerability there was
unnecessary there's some examples of
stabilities done by otherwise
intelligent people why because of the
concentration of power I think teaching
pain is often compared to mousy tone I
don't think that the comparison is
really a valid one but it is valid in so
far as he has reintroduced a single
point of failure into the Chinese system
and there is some reason for me to doubt
what kind of information how good
information is being reported outwards
or is it polished to such a high gloss
that it blinds the decision because
rather than informative yes sir there is
a packing they needed for the recording
well this episode is a continuation of
what happened in 2014 if you remember
the umbrella occupy central I think
although it manifests itself in various
political demands none of which can ever
be granted the underlying causes are
socio-economic Hong Kong is an extremely
unequal
xiety probably the most unequal society
in the world because it's the freest
market in the world every free market
even in the US has to be tempered a
little bit you know and it manifests
itself mainly in housing if you are
wrong but young person in Hong Kong
unless you come from a very rich family
in which you're not typical it's
impossible for you to own a house
Bloomberg did a study a few weeks ago
which I rewrite he said that the average
price of public house of a private house
a private apartment and in Hong Kong is
1.3 million u.s. dollars I mean it's out
of the reach of most people and what
they call an apartment in Hong Kong you
and I will call it closet you know okay
if you are going to rent something and
it's a state's idea young couple no
children both started working probably
two-thirds of their combined income I
have to go to him again for a glorified
closet this is not sustainable almost
all the land in Singapore is owned by
five or six tycoons and you know they
are acting perfil irrationally they keep
the price high it's a failure of
governance the percentage of people who
own their homes in Hong Kong is
something like forty four percent and I
would bet you that that 44 percent is
really at the top the number of people
who own the percentage of people that
own their homes in Singapore is
something like 92% and that's a matter
of policy it's a policy failure in the
first instance in Hong Kong there's a
lot of pent-up socio-economic
frustration now that said I actually
blame the British
Britain rule Hong Kong since the late
19th century 1850 something people
forget this as a colony not as a
democracy the Hong Kong people were
subjects they were not citizens it is
only on the death bed the very death bed
of British colonialism they got religion
and raised expectations in Hong Kong
that they knew full well no Chinese
government can can fulfill whether they
did that out of a belated sense of guilt
which I doubt because these are brits
after all do they feel guilt for you or
was it a poison challenge they decided
to leave behind I don't know but I went
to look at the career of Chris Patten
who was the last governor Hong Kong and
I cannot find a single bit of evidence
that he ever had any interest in Hong
Kong until he got that job first thing
right secondly Hong Kong people you know
the slogan one country two systems' Hong
Kong people and most of the people
outside Hong Kong always thought that
the emphasis was on two systems or at
least equal on one country to zero it's
quite clear from the very beginning the
emphasis of Beijing was on one country
first two systems later huh it has gone
on on-call people and thirdly is what I
told you about the tycoons the
socio-economic equality just about three
or four three weeks ago two weeks ago I
had a chance to talk to a bunch of young
people in Singapore from all over the
region including at four or five before
Hong Kong and these are other people you
know twenty-five bombs on the streets
although they were sympathetic to those
people and they were trying to count
them down and one of them told me you
see you gotta understand we all suddenly
realize that we are all only the
servants of the tycoons and we have been
betrayed by the British and we have been
betrayed by the change there
rage how are they n I don't know I don't
think the Chinese are particularly keen
to intervene directly they've got enough
troubles with the u.s. there was a
terrible miscalculation by sitting ping
another big mistake but they cannot at
the same time in my mind allow this to
go on indefinitely because it can only
if he goes on indefinitely
give PRC people inconvenient thoughts I
cannot see any of the demands being
granted I cannot see Kerala Chief
Minister Hong Kong be allowed to give in
to any of demands
okay what are the months is to have an
independent inquiry about police
brutality how can they get in somebody
would say let's have an independent
inquiry to Tiananmen so I don't see how
this is going to end by for China this
is the land of no good options there's
only a bad option worse option and right
now they don't even know which is better
which is worse
I think they are just buying time until
after first October and then they were
probably asked the Hong Kong police to
act more forcefully which the police
already acting more forcefully it could
perhaps you can under the basic law
declare martial law or curfew we should
you know implies curfew then you can try
to separate the hardcore supporters and
arrest them
I mean that thing they could do but
right now I think it is ready I think I
had a loss talking about Beijing Hong
Kong government has been at a loss for
quite some time but essentially I come
back to my first point it's a failure of
governance because every Hong Kong
government since 1997 has been in hot
off the tycoons and nobody has had the
will to break their power in fact I just
joked with a Chinese friend before
coming here your big mistake was not to
have land reform in Hong Kong after 1997
actually under 1949 I don't suggest that
you kill all the tycoons well you could
for example Hong Kong doesn't has no law
that allows the government to acquire
land with compensation it has no law
that requires a person owning a piece of
land to develop it with it Axios or
else's tax goes up you can keep it there
at no cost to yourself 400 years this is
not a way to run you know a corner
coffee shop let alone a country and I
think that's the route unless they
address that this thing will pop up
again and again and again
yes it depends on your interpretation of
post-millennial Chinese history there
are some people I don't bite myself who
see China I think China wants to be the
dominant power I don't think the
ambition can be achieved they will
certainly achieve have already achieved
a more prominent position and then in
the past but it will be a presenter we
have to share as I said in my lecture
with many other powers
how much is current Chinese for Policy
informed by ancient history well they
certainly use it to impress the
barbarians that's asked by the way but I
really much doubt it is like that right
what is true is that they have a very
long view of policy and they can have a
long view of policy because they don't
have to get elected every four years
that is some advantage but it is
counterbalanced by other disadvantage
some of which I just mentioned so you
can I mean they are very interesting
books written you know how a French for
example you know about this career else
right and I like reading them
because they are quite amusing and yeah
you know but I don't really buy it that
much they're not off you know this is
21st century you're not gonna do China
like you know in 2 to 1 BC here some of
the things they say come from Chinese
history the basic stratagems and all
that it's dead Machiavelli is there in
many you know western Texas as to meet
common sense of statecraft rather than
something uniquely Chinese actually
somewhere over there
[Music]
country is not enough
Indonesians burn down plantations and
from time to time cause I used all of
aids to descend on countries in
Southeast Asia there are a lot of
reasons for it development is one but
you can do you can clear the land
without necessarily burning everything
down it just happens to be the cheapest
way and and there are regulations in
Indonesia against doing the Saltine but
you know the usual incentives to people
to look the other way you apply so I
would say that in relations among us n
Singapore Malaysia Thailand Brunei I
have been affected by this and see and
Southeast Asia is not that huge a
physical space so - this is all these
problems we have to actually work with
each other the other aspect of this is
in Southeast Asia is on land I mention I
mentioned that may come run through five
countries and I hit waters of the Mekong
are in China in fact the may hit waters
of all the major Asian we rivers are in
China and China and Asia and the Mekong
is has plans to I think if I remember
the figure construct 21 dams of which at
least eight have already been
constructed what is the environment
impact of that downstream I'm not
talking now about the political
strategic use of this just thinking
about the environmental impact has any
proper study being done there simple
answer is no the only people claim to do
study
you know okay you you believe those
claims I've got this bridge I'll let you
have real cheap the same will apply for
china-india relations because when we
put try and all that they all start in
China now supposing the glaciers melt
because they all start on the Tibetan
Plateau and in the Himalayas where they
are very ungracious cointegration spell
and the water starts running dry and
everybody starts competing for water
there isn't any proper system of
regulating these things not what couple
won anyway all right so it's going to be
a big problem in the future however as I
was talking to a bunch of Singapore
students before I came here I said look
you know climate change is imposed is a
politically impossible
it's a politically impossible issue to
deal to be dealt with sensibly by any
system based on electoral politics I
don't want you to a democracy because
they are different types electoral
politics why because you pay the front
the cost which are horrendous up front
and the benefits I only read many many
years down the future so I'm a
politician and I go and talk to to to my
constituent and it says you know my
fellow whatever you know I'm afraid
you're gonna have to make this huge
sacrifices now and I have to raise your
taxes etc etc etc because of climate
change and oh by the way the benefits
will be felt by only your
great-great-great grandchildren you're
gonna get elected we my prime minister
of Singapore is the we do have elections
and even our worst enemies don't accuse
us of fixing the elections but we can't
take a long term view and my prime
minister thinks that we need to spend at
least 100 billion dollars over the next
hundred years to prepare Singapore for
future where sea levels are going to
rise now we are lucky we can do it we
are a small country we don't have much
options but small rich country has much
more options rather than a small poor
country and many other Southeast Asian
countries they are doing well
economically but they are not that rich
and they are much larger than us it's
going to be a huge problem
which is not being adequately dealt with
by anybody anywhere and I do not see any
good prospect of international action on
this either so every man for himself
every country for yourself you do what
you can and in the meantime we all die
I thought those young students I'll be
there don't worry it's your problem so
it is this is the hot fact of life at
least we do not have climate change
deniers in Singapore authorization none
day I drove it anyway
with that depressing answer everybody is
silenced gentleman has another question
[Music]
[Music]
it is it's probably generated but what
you may have heard I don't know no we do
not execute everybody for throwing
glitter on the floor we find them but we
don't kill them yeah we we have strict
laws in certain areas for example if you
are caught smuggling drugs above a
certain amount the presumption is you're
caught with drugs on you different types
of drugs have different limits above a
certain limit the presumption is you are
trafficking and if the limit is above a
certain amount it is a mandatory capital
punishment that's some people think this
is a terribly barbaric law but we don't
majority of Singaporeans don't think so
we still have capital punishment many
countries don't have it but I think you
take a poll of Singapore most people
were supported
we do have lost strict laws against
littering which is a fine not execution
I assure you
and that's why Singapore is pretty clean
we have and there are many other things
but I think that perception of Singapore
I've had people come to Singapore say we
are the policeman is nice not people
with machine guns there in every corner
if you have clear lots however strict
and and force them then you don't have
to have this heavy head
because people will obey the lost
problem in New York City I went to
Columbia University in the late 1970s
and you know New York City was a
terrible mess there we cost why because
it had many laws it's not the lack of
law you know they never enforced it for
whatever reason in heaven for say any
went to the docks
then you had well who was it well he's
gone mad now it was mr. Giuliani
now before in his in his relative in the
same days who decided to enforce the
laws even for small things and therefore
big things would follow whatever he's
done since is another matter but that
was a pretty sensible thing he did for
New York which clean up New York quite a
lot it was a dangerous place up uptown a
parasite Columbia it was a titter space
now now it's you know if anything to see
kinda boring so you have to have laws
it's not the strictness of punishments
it is the certainty that the laws will
be enforced that creates order where
things can be negotiated or are this is
too is too small the bored of it it's
only littering leave it alone well that
is what makes things go wrong I don't
think our laws are dead straight it is
trickier than in Western countries but
you know it's Victor then necessary
stricter than in the United States you
know you put people in jail at a drop of
a hat for things that we might not put
them in jail and for longer periods in
here
especially members of your family that
this lecture interesting and I'd like to
by everybody to come to reception
[Applause]
[Music]